about a year ago we first talked about
the growing community of people who call
themselves dinks now dink may sound like
some kind of racial slur but it's not uh
well I mean it was technically some
people used it as a pejorative term for
the Vietnamese during the Vietnam war
it's also a term familiar to my fellow
bass fisherman uh used to describe any
game Fish below 12 Ines in length but in
this case dink uh does not refer to
either Asians or small fish dink is an
acronym that stands for dual income no
kids so these are the child by choice
folks uh those who get married and could
have kids but choose instead to have a
Barren sterile relationship focused
entirely on their own superficial wants
and desires now the dinks are getting a
lot of attention these days especially
over the past week on Monday Business
Insider ran a piece titled meet the
typical dink they have over $200,000 in
the bank and aren't paying for pricey
Child Care the article tells us quote it
seems like everyone wants to be a dink
these days dink households that are
double income with no kids are seeing
their ranks grow especially as a High
Cost of Living and the climate crisis
weigh particularly on people with
children there are variations on the
dink or the sink single income no kids
you could be a dink wad which means
double income no kids with a dog dink
wads who previously spoke to Business
Insider said that the lifestyle gives
them Financial stability the capacity to
travel and the ability to dodge the ever
increasing cost of Parenthood and it's
lifestyle that's paying off as dinks
emerge on top of a shaky economy so who
are the dinks of America their ranks are
set to grow they're making six figures
and they want to spend their money on
their pets and traveling yes dink wad if
you have a dog or I guess dink whack if
you have a cat or dink if you own a
pony or a pig or a parrot or if you're a
big cardi B fan there are many
variations but they all boil down to the
fact that you have decided to not have
kids and as the article details this is
a rapidly growing Group quote around 5%
of the country's total population was
cohabitating couples who do not live
with a child under 18 and around 29% of
the total population are married couples
who do not live with a child under 18
according to the 2022 American Community
survey data among unmarried couples that
figure is slightly up from 2019 when
4.4% of the population was cohabitating
couples not living with a child under 18
the US Census Bureau also finds that the
Aging population is increasingly
childfree as of 2018 over one in seven
women were childless by the time they
were between the ages of 40 and 44
that's higher than the one in 10 women
who were in the same boat as of 1976 a
Pew survey found that 44% % of
non-parents Ages 18 to 49 said that they
were not likely or not at all likely to
have kids at all someday up from
37% okay but what is the dink existence
really like well this week there has
also been for whatever reason a sudden
surge in Tik Tok videos promoting this
lifestyle and um most of them kind of
follow the same annoying format which
looks like this watch We're dinks we go
to Trader Joe's and workout classes on
the weekends we're dinks we get get into
snobby Hobbies like skiing and golfing
or dinks we can go to Florida on a whim
we're dinks we're already planning our
european vacation next year dinks we get
a full eight hours of sleep and
sometimes more we're dinks we get
desserts and appetizers at restaurants
we're dinks we can play with other kids
and give them back we're dinks we still
do it three times a week we're dinks we
spend our discretionary income on $8
latte we're dinks we max out our 401ks
Roth IRA and hsas we're dinks we don't
use our kids or dog as an excuse to
leave a party we just
leave yes well I'm a cisk single income
six kids and I can do you one better I
make no excuse to leave a party because
I just don't go to parties in the first
place but I guess it has more to do with
being aswick antisocial with kids which
isn't much different from being asok
antisocial without kids but in any case
you may notice that most of the things
they're bragging about besides the
ability to leave social Gatherings when
they want to which I guess they imagine
for some reason is something parents
aren't able to do but most of the things
all revolve around their increased
ability to buy stuff and this is a theme
that runs through basically all of the
dink propaganda watch We're dinks we're
going to get asked daily when we plan on
having kids we're dinks of course we're
going to go out to eat every night after
work we're dinks we don't have to ask
our family for financial help or to
watch our kid when we want to go out
we're dinks we're going to go to Costco
and buy all the snacks in bulk that we
want we're dinks we have disposable
income to spend on whatever we would
like and don't have to spend on a kid
we're dinks I'm going to go to Every
football game and play 18 holes whenever
I want we're dinks we're going to get
asked to every single family event what
we're doing with our life yes we're
dinks we can buy things we can consume
look at all the consuming we do we are
such dedicated consumers you dumb
parents with your dumb children you
can't possibly devote as much of your
life to buying and eating which is
literally the only thing we care about
in this world apparently and this is the
message over and over again another
example we're dinks we're going to be
asked constantly by family friends and
strangers when we're going to have kids
we're dinks we're going to go to Costco
and buy all the snacks we want we're
dinks we're going to support our friends
who have kids even if we decide to never
have any we're dinks we're going to
have we're dinks we're going to have
lots of we're dinks we're going to have
lots of disposal income to spend on
whatever we
like we're dinks we're going to get
chastised by people on the internet
because they're going to assume that
we're just obsessed with material things
even though arguably you need a lot more
material things once you have kids or
inks we don't need to find a sitter or
rope our family into babysitting when we
want to go out for the night we're dinks
we're going to be told the only way that
will ever be fulfilled in life is by
having kids we're dinks we're going to
book flights whenever we feel like it
we're dinks we're still going to stick
to a strict budget to meet our financial
goals no matter how much wiggle room we
have in our finan is we're dinks we're
not going to make a life-altering choice
just because everybody else is doing it
period now as you're probably noticing
uh these people apparently have a weird
preoccupation with Costco they're making
videos providing unsolicited lists of
the things that make their lives
fulfilling and somehow Costco makes the
cut uh here's another one watch We're
kid free so we love to treat our furry
babies just like children we're kid-free
we always get beautiful night's sleep
and sometimes a nap we're kid-free so
obviously everyone's going to ask us so
when are you going to have
kids we're kid-free we love our family
and friends kids even if we don't want
our own you're
high you're high I wish we're kid-free
Karens are constantly going to tell us
aren't we afraid of missing out what if
you never feel fully fulfilled or
unconditional love without them well
Karen don't you think that's a lot of
pressure to put on your kids all of your
needs
I think we'll be okay we're kid-free
with only two mouse to feed we can
prioritize better Costco
snacks okay this Costco thing is really
getting out of control but let's just
just one more
video why is nobody talking about Bean
dinks well I'm freshly married and I'm
going to talk about it here's our life
as dinks in our early 30s no shocker
here folks today we went to
Costco okay enough with Costco I mean I
like to buy cereal wholesale too but I'm
not going to make it my whole identity
so let's let's get a grip you know your
online data includes personal
information such as your name address
phone number email address financial
information and login credentials
hackers want to steal this information
and sell it on the dark web where it can
be used for various criminal activities
such as fishing ransomware and identity
theft needless to say it's incredibly
important that you use a VPN to prevent
that from happening but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important that's
why I recommend using expressvpn every
time you go online Express VN makes you
Anonymous uh online by camouflaging your
IP address and replacing it with a
different secure IP of your choice
Express also encrypts all of your data
so that it's protected from hackers
anybody else that might be trying to spy
on you express UPN is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app click one
button and it's done plus works on all
my devices my phone my laptop even my
Wi-Fi router so if you're like me and
you believe your internet data belongs
to you then expressvpn is the answer if
it's expressvpn.com mat Walsh show and
get three extra months free that's EXP
rsvpn
docomo expressvpn.com
Walsh show to learn more so so what's
what's really going on here let's take a
step back and first of all a few
points uh number one are you really
trying to take ownership of Costco as
childless people that's like saying that
a benefit of being childless is that you
get to go to the Rainforest Cafe I mean
those places exist for us for parents
that is our domain and for the record I
buy whatever snacks I want for myself
whenever I want them whether from Costco
or anywhere else my children do not
prevent me from indulging in that way
the only difference is that if anybody
ask me to provide a list of the things
that I love most about my life I
wouldn't cite the fact that I can buy
snacks for myself okay if somebody were
to come to me and say what do you what's
the greatest thing about being you Matt
what do you love the most well I can buy
snacks I wouldn't say that not because I
can't buy snacks but because that's a
rather banal detail that I would think
is probably not worth mentioning and yet
for d a snacks and Costco play
apparently a central role in their lives
on their deathbeds while they're lying
there alone with no one to mourn them or
care that they're dying or remember them
when they're gone if the hospice nurse
who's the only person who's going to be
in the room with them asks them to pass
along a final piece of wisdom they will
look up and with their final dying
breath they will whisper get a Costco
membership they have great deals
on
Jesus see a person's life has to revolve
around something has to be dedicated to
something and even by their own
testimony it's clear that when people
choose to be childless their lives
inevitably revolve around pure
self-centered unadulterated unencumbered
consumption that's not my accusation
that's listen to them any one of these
videos where these childless people talk
about the benefits of being childless
that's them saying it is that is that
think of all the consumption we can
do now of course it's true that the same
is the case for many parents in the
modern world I mean there are many
parents who their lives also revolve
around consumption but uh at least if
you ask the average parent however they
may actually live their lives they will
at least say that the thing that gives
them purpose and joy is their
relationship with their children and
their spouses they will talk about their
families as the foundation of their
lives that shows at the very least that
they are aspiring to something higher
and greater than themselves whether or
not they actually live up to their own
aspirations is a different story but the
dinks don't even aspire to the
Transcendent for them there is no
meaning in life except in their ability
to sleep and eat and buy stuff it is a
deeply nihilistic way to live and this
is what makes the rise of the dinks so
catastrophic that is aside from the more
immediate and obvious fact that this is
a community which if it reaches critical
mass would actually bring about the end
of mankind which by the way is a pretty
good indication that you're making a bad
lifestyle Choice okay if your lifestyle
is one that if adopted by a majority of
humans would spell the end of the human
species then that is a very powerful
sign that there is something seriously
wrong with your
lifestyle but aside from that if it's
possible to put that detail aside the
rise of the childless by choice
demographic is the rise of a group that
has in principle given up on finding any
meaning in life beyond the
multiplication and satisfaction of
desire to use doki's phrase they're so
dedicated to this calling so intent on
consumption that they are willing to end
their own Bloodlines to pursue it they
are willing to commit a sort of
ancestral
suicide just so they have more time to
buy
stuff now just consider specifically
that overweight male dink in the video
who's especially excited about Costco
well one of them anyway because they all
were but uh take take one of those guys
and just put them in your in your
mind hey
ancestors fought and struggled and
persevered and pioneered and bled and
suffered all so that he could
exist and and he stands now at the end
of a procession that stretches back into
the ancient past we all do right every
single one of us a a a line of people
who made his very existence possible who
migrated thousands of miles and fought
Wars and tamed wildernesses and Built
Homes and civilizations all for him and
he turns back to those people to his
ancestors to his blood and he says uh
yeah sorry guys we're done we're done
here uh you know I'm going to end the
bloodline right here I'd rather have
some extra spending cash to buy Doritos
I've
decided the sheer hubris is
astounding though of course I realized
that this man would be totally mystified
by the notion that he has any
responsibility at all to his family his
ancestry his bloodline
much less to the God who created him he
hasn't thought about any of this he's
thought only about his own immediate
happiness but in pursuing happiness
above all happiness through luxury
happiness through consumption he will
miss it because happiness comes from
fulfillment and fulfillment comes from
doing that which you are made to do okay
it comes from finding your place in that
ancient ancestral struggle from taking
part in it from from building the Next
Generation so that the fight can go on
happiness comes from fulfilling your
purpose in life it comes from pursuing
the
Transcendent not the
transactional
so the dinks will grow in number but
they will also grow in misery they will
live superficial lives and they will die
Anonymous
deaths and if they have their way
they'll take down all of civilization
with
them but at least they'll get to spend
more time at
Costco thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts